i think the u.s is facing some kind of
fracturing
but a lot of people talk about a
peaceful divorce i think we've already
broken apart
you know i talked about this before
right joe biden comes out and says you
know we
come on man you know we need new
restrictions for govind and texas and
florida are like nah
if if you don't have red states
trusting the president and agreeing to
work together towards a common goal
then then the president just represents
the blue states
maybe maybe they're look i'm a young guy
i guess young enough
maybe there were periods in american
history where
states half the states were saying no to
the president
maybe maybe that was a hundred some odd
years ago the last time we had a civil
war right
yeah i mean i don't i don't think we're
going to civil war
it's not going to be what you think it
is it's not going to be civil war is
informational
right not with arms that's that's that's
exactly what i'm saying
it's fourth and fifth generational
warfare yeah so the point i'm making is
we're well past that point like china's
not going to march into india
with guns they're going to buy more and
more land they're doing it
they're buying up property in the u.s
like crazy they're buying up property in
brazil like
crazy and then their citizens naturally
just move into these areas and then live
in these places
using the existing laws they don't need
to march in with guns when they can
march with economics
same thing in the united states the
civil war we're experiencing is the
culture war it is a cold civil war
there i shouldn't even say it's cold
because people have literally been shot
and killed
you know notably in portland for
instance but it's not like factions with
armies marching towards each other
the issue is the best example is joe
biden comes out
talks about covid florida texas other
red states just look at joe biden and
say buzz off
we do not take your advice and we do not
care what you think
so you got blue states saying you got it
joe and red state's saying we don't
agree with the president
we are already split into two different
realities
you want to live like normal florida's a
waiting you go you've got to wear a mask
anymore you can go shopping go to the
movies everything's back to normal go to
new york
new york is now the epicenter again and
they're saying oh no it's it's bad we
got to do more lockdowns you go to
europe
europe's locking down like crazy yeah
here in the us to see blue states go the
exact
opposite direction of red states no
unity at
all i do find that interesting though
that
i mean like the division has been
happening for a while
i mean just look at you know you go
rewind 10 years
ago i mean think of how many states just
rejected you know obamacare coming into
their states
exactly and that's that's why a lot of
people do believe
obama was the time that this division
happened but i'm like look
i think it started before that right you
can reduce it further and further look
at al gore and george w
bush yeah it was a supreme court
appointment of a president no matter
what you believe
there's half the country who believes
bush only became president because the
supreme court intervened
right now there's a lot of people who
say no no george bush won fair and
square
no no no the realities are divergent at
that point there's there's democrats who
are saying it was stolen it was stolen
it was stolen
and there you go yeah then you get eight
years of that then obama comes in
then you get people were accusing were
claiming it was stolen back then
like even even donald trump was saying
that you know romney and the interesting
thing about that is a lot of people
tied the supreme court fight of the 2000
election
to distracting our intelligence agencies
from what al qaeda was up to
in the lead of that's right because
there was no transition the transition
was so
it was so rocky it was delayed and it
was lifted up
yeah between the clinton and the bush
administrations that a lot of people
look at that
as the one area where al qaeda basically
made its move
to enact uh to basically attack the
united states through 9 11.
i think that was where we saw a big
political split but an interesting
thing an interesting thing happened in
2008 with the economic crisis because we
had we had ben stewart here he was
talking about
strass how generational theory are you
familiar with that no i'm not
it it's this theory that there are four
seasons a season lasts
20 years you've got spring summer fall
and winter
after winter this great conflict this
great crisis comes a spring
where everything is really good the
economy blossoms and booms
then you have a summer where it's
maintained and people are happy then a
fall where things start getting shaky
and chaotic and then a winter again
where the chaos breaks out
so right now we are in the winter period
80 years ago the end of the last winter
was world war ii
80 years before that it was the civil
war 80 years before that
the revolutionary war and apparently
they've mapped out like all of these
things that
have happened every 80 years it's based
on generations are you familiar with
that saying
strong men make good times good good men
uh
strong men make good times good times
make weak men weak men make hard times
hard times make strong matters it's
similar to that idea
that when you have a generation of
people who who fought through the
trenches
and many who didn't survive only the
strongest survive and come back
and create a flourishing strong society
of prosperity
their children inherit that world and
don't necessarily understand what it
took to create it
the next generation inherits a world
where they just feel entitled to it
which leads to chaos and collapse
interesting so it feels like
you know we're basically in this period
now
where we can expect i guess the the
the winter is here it's going to get bad
and it's supposed to end around 2028 but
my point was
the point i wanted to get to with 2008
was when we talk about when the
political divide started and when cast
started to happen
they predicted in like 1990s when they
wrote this book called the fourth
turning
that in 2008 when boomers became
eligible for social security
the economic system was going to
collapse right perhaps
everything we know about what caused the
crisis mortgage-backed securities and
things like that
was actually just all the boomers now
demanding their entitlements
that didn't exist and figure out how to
cover it up
how not covered up but like cover the
costs
when you look at the m1 money supply
it's slowly stagnant over several
decades
2008 happens it increases by like by a
factor of 10 or whatever it just like
spikes upward money creation is going up
rapidly
then the pandemic hits skyrockets
straight up
they change the way they report the
money stock mid pandemic
and now no one knows for sure but you
can see 2008
where the money supply just goes boom
and takes a sharp turn upward
maybe mortgage-backed security crisis
they were giving out homes to everybody
and people couldn't pay for it
or maybe our financial system was broken
we knew it was broken
it was predicted that it was going to
break and then it broke
i've heard that this theory that they
used covid as an excuse to print
because they had to print because
everything was falling apart it's it's
it's it's a
a conspiracy was it you was telling me
this someone basically i think it was
you
who mentioned this they were saying that
democrats
uh uh made bad bets and investments that
went sour
and was going to completely disrupt
pensions and 401ks and retirement plans
was it you said no
who's who told us that i don't remember
hearing that yeah i was hearing uh
there's a conspiracy theory that what
actually happened was
kofi's legit and we we had a pen
democratic crisis
and we had 15 days to slow the spread
however
the economic crisis was real we're
supposed to have
you know they say every 10 years is like
an economic downturn of some sort and we
kind of dodged that for some reason
i heard a conspiracy theory i'm not
saying it's true i think it's literally
probably not true
that democrats made bad bets with you
know unions made bad bets
they could you know they made bad
investments the investments soured
and then when covet hit they knew that
there was going to be a serious collapse
of retirement funds and people's 401ks
and things like that
so they were like we need a bailout we
saw all these blue states now this this
part is true
you know cuomo for instance being like
new york needs money and trump was like
shove it too bad run your state better
now we get the 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus
and republicans are calling it a bailout
for blue states that are poorly managed
so i don't know i don't know i don't
know about i mean
i mean yeah they had the 2.2 trillion
dollar stimulus a year ago right
um and it's covering the i mean look new
york's crumbling
they're the the metro for instance the
mta they're struggling to repair it
they're not making enough money as to
how much it costs
so you had that whole situation with aoc
where amazon was going to come in bring
these 40 000 jobs potentially 30 billion
over 10 years they needed that money to
fix their train systems
that didn't it didn't happen and i i
guess
interestingly enough with the the amount
of people that are probably leaving new
york because of the
the lockdowns i can imagine they're
probably going to be making way for
um you know a vacuum of sorts but i
wonder man
i mean bill de blasio said he's gonna
buy up these buildings
turn it into public housing i wonder if
the economy is just worse than we
realize
and they're not going to tell us because
panic would only make it worse right
well yeah obviously if they came out and
said my fellow americans
several large unions with hundreds of
thousands of members
put their money in dangerous places and
lost the retirements of millions of
of middle-class americans this is going
to result result in a ripple effect that
wipes out if
if they said something like that yeah
people would freak out oh hundred
percent
crash the banks remember exactly
remember what george w bush said after 9
11.
which part how old are you i'm 33.
all right so you should remember this
yeah he said
go buy stuff he said you'll buy stuff
well because the atta the 911 attack was
in addition to being an actual terrorist
attack
on the the people it was an attack on
our financial center
and what he was basically saying was if
you want to help
go out and buy things to keep the
economy moving
when when that attack happened and
people are panicking you get a natural
reaction from a lot of people to stock
up
store up save your money and bunker down
right and he was like no no the
machine's got to keep churning
you need to keep the machine going so we
generate taxes so we can pay for this
stuff so we can build new things
go buy stuff that's a scary prospect
because that can't last forever can it
right
so so i don't know exactly you know if
any conspiracy is true i would actually
argue they're probably not that's why we
call them conspiracies
but i will say you can look at the
crisis in 2008 the mass printing of
money
it was only a matter of time before we
were gonna see that bubble burst it
could not be maintained do you remember
how much the 2008 bailout was for i was
looking for like for 989
million dollars yeah that was our
billion that was what was on the books
i'm reading an article here
from that's too small this article from
mit quotes a 2015 forbes article that
says we've paid back 4.6 trillion
of the 16.8 trillion that we committed
to that bailout
over i don't know how many years 15 or
20 years or something now this is forbes
reporting that okay um i don't if if we
secretly committed 16 trillion
in 2008 and we're still paying it back
maybe that's
another explanation for why they just
flooded the market with 12 trillion
the fractional banking fractional
reserve system it is a stack of cards it
is literally a ponzi scheme
and it works because we have guns so at
a certain point
it's gonna fall apart like you guys
understand how this how bank how banking
in this country works right fractional
reserve as far as i understand is the
federal
the federal reserve will loan a bank a
million dollars the bank then can loan
out ninety percent of that
so they can loan out nine they need to
keep ten percent on reserve yeah but
they're not
that loan is creating the money supply
so
when you when you give a hundred dollars
to a bank
they can then loan out ninety dollars
which is created on the books
and then expanding to another bank then
that other bank takes that 90 and can
loan out
81. no not necessarily they loan it to
you so they give you
so i i put 100 bucks in in the bank of
ian
then the bank of ian is able to give a
90 loan
to the bank of cer to to suraj as an
individual
survivor get my you don't get your own
bank not yet but then you deposit you're
90 bucks
you deposit your 90 bucks into the bank
of lydia
now lydia can loan out 90 whoa whoa guys
it sounds a little bit racist
talk about it well i don't got a bank
either oh i thought you just said
federal reserve so so the point is
a bank gives an individual money the
individual puts it in a bank
that bank then loans out then an
individual loans puts it back into bank
so it's just basically a stack of cards
it's basically a game of hot potato
and where the debt keeps stacking up the
interest becomes impossible to pay
and then obama signs a massive stimulus
the money printing goes out of control
this was predictable a long time ago i
mean when did we go off the gold
standard that was nineteen seventy
seventy yeah the seventy two seven seven
seventy three shock
you know what the issue there was it's
really really simple
if all four of us here in this room are
trading
you know one dollar between each other
so it's like i give ian a dollar in
exchange for a high five then ian gives
suraj a dollar a chance for a high five
the only way to get that high five is to
have the dollar and make it to you
so at one point i decide you know what i
don't wanna have to give away a high
five to get that dollar
i want all the high fives for myself so
i tell all of you hey guys i'm gonna
manage the money printer
don't worry i'll make sure everything's
good and then when you guys are paying
attention i just print money for myself
i don't do any work basically what
happens is we're able to fund all of
these wars and all this conflict
because the fed can print out money loan
it to however they want without
contributing anything to society
we've got missing missing uh trillions
of dollars on the books or whatever from
the pentagon some some nonsense
we've not audited the fed we need we
need to figure out how much money is
being printed who's it
who's it who it's going to and we don't
know at a certain point
if they can just snap their fingers and
create money on the books and we don't
understand the system
other people are exploiting it the house
of cards is going to fall over
yeah that's it and i mean you you
inspired me to make a great idea i'm
definitely gonna start charging people
for high fives yes particularly
specifically kids thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you